hello
in this lecture we talk about parity and
parity violation
um so we talk about a discrete symmetry
[Music]
a little bit of history in particle
physics lee and young
in the 1950s wondered
if there's any experiment testing
parity invariants there were many tests
which had to do with a strong
interaction
and electromagnetic interaction but as
it turned out
parity invariants had never been tested
in weak interaction
and so lee and young were motivated in
this because there was a
puzzle at the time so-called tau theta
puzzle
which turned out to be k on decays into
various articles and in that
puzzle they saw um the case
with the same lifetime but different um
um spin states and so they couldn't
quite
understand this and we're trying to
understand whether or not one can
have an experiment to test this so the
experiment they proposed
is one where you look at a nuclei and
observe beta decay so there's an
electron coming out of the beta decay
if you are able to align the spin of the
nuclei
and put this in front of a mirror you
see that the physics
going to the mirror state is not
conserving parity
you see that you know in the mirror the
spin the opposite direction
but the momentum of the electrons the
electrons still come out in the bottom
so there's clearly some change
in the physics going on in the mirrored
state
so madame boo actually took up this idea
and immediately tested this in the same
year
she was a chinese-american physicist
born in china
and then studied in berkeley
together with famous people there um
lawrence is one of them um after the war
or in the war she uh
joined the manhattan project and made
very very uh
important contribution to the manhattan
project based on her cesar's work
as a fun fact she was married to another
chinese american
the grandson of the first president
of the republic of china as i said in
1956 she conducted the wu experiment
and in the following year received the
nobel prize in physics
for the finding so really briefly we're
going to have another discussion of the
wu experiment later on
what she did here is she studied a
global sixth cobalt 60 decay into nickel
beta decays and what she was able to do
experimentally
with the magnetic field align the cobalt
60
and then just count the number of
electrons coming out and it turns out
that
number of electrons coming out on the
bottom and the top are not the same
she did this by reverting the magnetic
field and the
experimental data is shown here you see
as a function of time so you
you know you just look at counting
weights as a function of time after
injecting the probe
um and you revert you do the measurement
by reverting the magnetic field
you see very clearly here that there is
an asymmetry
in the better decays and that asymmetry
immediately tells you that there has to
be
parity violation in better decays
or in weak interaction so she found
that this uh specific picture here
bioli violates uh parity and this is a
dramatic signature of the read
interaction and we'll let us see how we
can actually understand this note that
parity is conserved in electromagnetic
interaction in the strong interaction
one more word on parity invasion an
inversion you can define a parity
operator
and if you apply this parity operator
for example on a vector
with x y and z components you simply
turn the direction over here with a
minus sign
you